le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et déjà prêts
à accueillir les jeux olympiques seul
projet francilien avoir survécu à la
candidature de paris 2012
la structure a officiellement été
inauguré en janvier 2014
depuis cette date le site s'éroder en
l'organisant les championnats du monde
de cyclisme sur piste en 2015 et les
championnats d'europe l'année suivante
une expérience qui a impressionné le cio
pendant son passage
bien sûr ça lève le doute sur sur toutes
les interrogations qu'on pourrait avoir
la l'équipement il est là il a été testé
et l'a accueilli déjà la plus grandes
échéances internationales avec les
championnats du monde donc je pense que
tout ça c'est forcément des garanties
pour le cio pour accueillir les
supporters pendant lé giro 5000 places
ont été construites dans la structure on
a une proximité avec la piste voilà
puisque au delà de la balustrade le
public est juste là il peut être à un
mètre finalement des coureurs qui
passent avec des vitesses élevées un des
coureurs qui atteignent 70 quasiment 80
km heure sur les épreuves de sprint
donc voilà toute cette ambiance et ce
show très spectaculaire sur la piste
avec le public généralement et et
et soutient et supporter grandement ses
athlètes le spectacle se passe également
sous la piste les 250 m pour 8 de large
sont entretenus régulièrement pour
mettre les athlètes dans les meilleures
conditions
ses références et donc on voit à quel
niveau en mai puisque par exemple en cas
de chute on peut être amené à remplacer
des tasseaux de bois sur lesquels les
coureurs roulent par le dessous donc
voilà on peut essayer de se repérer là
on voit que bien sûr on est dans une
courbe donc dans un des deux virages de
la piste une charpente en bois qui est
déjà marquée par les performances des
pistards tricolore sur la piste du
vélodrome nationale là bas on à grégory
baugé multiples champions du monde qui
était aux derniers aux derniers jeux
olympiques
quentin lafargue médaillé de bronze ici
aux championnats du monde sur piste
là on à michael d'almeida qui est
multiple médaillé olympique la nouvelle
génération rêve sans doute d'imiter
leurs aînés en inscrivant leur nom sur
les poutres du vélodrome après une
médaille d'or aux jeux olympiques
la dédicace sera peut être programmé
pour 2024